challes bonnaire bonjour bonjour vous
êtes candidate à l'élection municipale
dans la commune du marin pourquoi
êtes-vous candidate michel bonnaire est
ce que le fait que le maire sortant en
place depuis longtemps or on le sait
depuis très longtemps même rodolphe
désiré ne se représente pas est-ce que
ce fait a joué un rôle important dans
votre décision
alors d'abord bonjour à tous les
auditeurs
cette décision a été prise le 26 mai
2010 huit ans avec un groupe qui s'était
réuni les jeunes depuis plusieurs mois
et bien évidemment le fait que le maire
se soit décidée en janvier 2019 n'a
absolument rien à voir avec ma prise de
décision maintenant il a free
certainement une sage décision
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une ère de
transmission et il faille que la
jeunesse que les nouvelles générations
prennent le flambeau pour poursuivre
l'activité l'action politique
mais en tout cas et essayer de donner à
cette ville du marin qui est une très
belle ville une autre direction
le vuvuzela river un petit peu à vous
entendre on a l'impression que vous vous
présentez presse comme une forme de deux
dauphines mais d'héritière des
mandatures d'offres désirer alors pas du
tout vous savez j'ai été toujours dans
l'opposition lilloise
c'est pour ça que ça un petit peu au
jour dans l'opposition marine oise
maintenant vous savez il n'est pas
normalement dit parce que quelqu'un dans
l'opposition qu'on ne sera pas forcément
d'accord avec certaines choses
maintenant la politique doivent changer
aux marins plus de proximité plus de
considération pour la population qui la
demandent d'ailleurs notamment durant
tous nos portes à portes que nous
effectuons le plus le mois de février au
monde la déclaration nous entendons par
tous la même chose nous avons été
oubliés par l'équipe municipale
donc c'est un peu une volonté de venir
en tout cas en aide à cette population
qui le demandent
et puis les missions régaliennes qui ne
sont malheureusement pas bien fait
on parle bien évidemment des routes d
de tout au tout l'élagage qui devrait
être fait de l'aide qui pourrait être
apportée quand il ya des situations de
crise par exemple comme la dernière fois
où il ya eu des éboulements
une réactivité qui que l'on ne reconnaît
plus haut niveau de la municipalité
donc je crois qu'il fait y retrouver
plus d'efficacité plus d'équité aussi
dans le fonctionnement au niveau de
cette municipalité
alors parmi tout ce que vous venez de
citer si vous étiez élu michel bonnet
maire du marin quelle est la priorité
pour vous pour votre équipe municipale
pour améliorer la situation du marin de
ses habitants quel serait le dossier que
vous prendriez en main tout de suite
alors avant même de commencer à prendre
les dossiers
je souhaite que la population marinoise
se disent qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
nouvelle équipe qui n'a aucun a priori
envers quiconque
donc nous n'avons aucun a priori cela
signifie que nous faisons confiance à
tout le monde
nous voulons en retour que cette
population nous fasse confiance et bien
évidemment ça sera le 15 mars 2020 quel
pour elle aura la possibilité de le
faire donc renouer un peu de confiance
faire en sorte qu'ils voient les élus
que nous ne soyons pas les élus fantômes
comme souvent ça se fait ce sera ça
votre priorité
ma priorité c'est ça la deuxième nous
avons un personnel qui a beaucoup de
valeur j'ai envie de dire que c'est ce
personnel qui tient la maison en général
pour toutes les missions qu'elles soient
administratives ou techniques
il faut renouer aussi des liens puisque
la grève qui a eu lieu il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça montre qu'il ya
effectivement un malaise et ce n'est pas
le premier mouvement de grève qu'il ya
eu dans quoi nouer des liens avec un
personnel qui se sentent plus en
confiance qu'ils nous fassent part de
leurs doléances notamment en termes de
conditions de travail
voilà alors il nous reste une minute
donc en une minute s'il vous plaît
michel bonnet recalé pour vous
l'enjeu de ce scrutin du point de vue de
l'intérêt général de la commune un
scrutin d'ailleurs où s'annonce tout de
même il faut le souligner une lutte
fratricide entre successeurs potentiels
du même camp que le maire sortant 1
tout à fait effectivement il ya deux
candidats dans l'équipe majorité a
aujourd'hui 30 secondes mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que moi je regarde pas
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ce que je
veux c'est avancer tout simplement faire
en sorte que la population comprenne
notre projet on veut véritablement
prendre en compte leurs demandes et
c'est pour ça qu'on a entamé ce circuit
au niveau de proximité au niveau des
quartiers pour que tout se passe
correctement et que notre projet réponde
à leurs attentes
michel bonheur merci merci à vous et
merci à tous les auditeurs